le communiqué officiel de l'Elysée est
tombé peu avant midi cette décision a
été prise afin de pouvoir accueillir sa
Majesté le roi Charles III dans des
conditions qui correspondent à notre
relation d'amitié la visite du roi
Charles III en France est reportée pour
cause de manifestations mardi prochain
décision prise conjointement par
Emmanuel Macron et le souverain
britannique qui viennent de s'entretenir
par téléphone quelques minutes plus tôt
à partir du moment où hier soir
l'intersyndicat l'a annoncé une nouvelle
journée de mobilisation mardi et que la
visite du roi était prévue de lundi à
mercredi je pense que nous ne serions
pas sérieux et nous manquerions d'un
certain bon sens a proposé à Sa Majesté
le Roi et la reine qu'on sort de venir
faire une visite d'État au milieu des
manifestations je me souviens quand
votre Mitterrand ou bien chiracula
Guillet
aujourd'hui c'est des petits zizi tout
petit qui se battent pour nous diriger
et puis après je me souviens plus très
bien
la réforme des retraites poursuit son
chemin Laurent Berger demande une pause
Emmanuel Macron le remercie je cite de
sa volonté d'apaisement dans le détail
pourtant une main tendue presque
inattendue je suis à la disposition de
la terre syndicale si elle souhaite
venir me rencontrer pour avancer sur
tous ces sujets quel sujet précisément
des sujets comme l'usure professionnelle
les fins de carrière les reconversions
les conditions de travail les
rémunérations dans certaines branches
on est pour la République et on est
contre la réforme contre la réforme
[Rires]
il y a 300 artistes qui ont signé la
Roussin également une tribune pour
demander le retrait de la réforme de
retraite pourquoi
et ouais bah non mais parce que
déjà ce passage en force du 49.3 de
vraiment insupportable cette
réforme est retour en arrière qui
concerne les retraites est absolument
inaudibles elles étaient bien allées
manifester avec Monique à Paris et comme
dans une manif chacun a ses atouts
Polska est Toutatice elle était venue
avec leur slogan
la France en colère
le 25 mars 1982 l'âge départ l'âge légal
de départ passe de 62 à 60 ans c'est
dans ce sens-là ça paraît complètement
fou aujourd'hui c'était une promesse de
campagne de François Mitterrand alors
évidemment les Français dans la rue à
cette époque-là sont plutôt contents de
cette nouvelle madame qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de la retraite à 60 ans je trouve
que c'est trop jeune
[Applaudissements]
mêlé avec ce tweet l'âge de la retraite
en France c'est trop bas c'est un vrai
problème pour le Washington Post malgré
les protestations mais des réformes
comme celles de Macron sont nécessaires
et pas qu'en France des solutions
étaient proposées
par exemple l'égalité salariale entre
les hommes et les femmes ce serait 6
milliards donc il y a des tas de
solutions et en fait c'est tout
simplement une volonté politique point
c'est pas il y a pas un déficit comme on
nous dit tout le temps trou de la
Sécurité
non l'hôpital déficit non c'est une
volonté politique des moyens
considérables sont déployés le jeune
homme recommence à culpabiliser ça va
toujours
ça va bouger un peu
partout
c'est gratuit les secours sont gratuits
écoute-moi
à faire mais non pas plus que toi tout
l'argent de nos impôts sert à ça à ce
que on est dans un pays justement
exemplaire ouais dans le dos de pays il
y a pas la sécurité sociale mais soyons
un modèle bordel donc il y a quelque
chose enfin pardon
c'est quand même quelque chose qui
caractérise ce qu'on en vient à la
France je vois que tout le monde y soit
pour profiter un petit peu parce que
quand on a travaillé 40 ans 45 ans va
vous savez on a besoin de repos
on est bien d'accord on est un peu loin
des débat actuels mais finalement on
entend un peu toujours les mêmes choses
est tout à fait c'est chaine info quelle
qu'elle soit il y en a qui sont plus
doués que d'autres pour faire du du
putaclic ou du ou du bad boys
c'est qu'elles vont elles vont chercher
l'angle le prixme la voiture qui prend
feu qui va tourner en boucle sur les
grands écrans derrière les présentateurs
alors que ça a été un incident qui est
arrivé mais on a l'impression que c'est
le pays entier les faits ce sont
déroulés lundi soir dernier en marge
d'une manifestation dans la capitale
alors qu'il est interpellé par la
bravème la brigade de répression de
l'action violente motorisée un jeune
homme enregistre discrètement les
échanges avec les policiers menaces
insultes pendant une vingtaine de
minutes les fonctionnaires de police
enchaînent les propos humiliants
des fois je m'en souviens
[Musique]
tu commences à bégayer t'en veux
peut-être une non pour te remettre la
mâchoire droite c'est moi qui t'a mis la
balayette en première je peux te dire si
tu veux revenir dans la rue travaille
ton cardio mon grand tu as traversé la
rue tu étais aussi qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de la police
pas grand chose moi je suis étranger
alors des fois je suis
embêté par la police je suis pour la
police et au combat il en faut il en
fauteuil d'avantage je pense que
justement elle pourrait très bien être
même plus énergique pour être là
bonne ambiance pendant la Révolution
française t'inquiète ta petite fille
et je peux te dire que nous les têtes on
est vachement fusion on les retiens ne
t'inquiète pas que la prochaine fois
qu'on vient tu monteras pas dans le car
pour aller au commissariat tu vas monter
dans un autre truc qu'on appelle
ambulance par la l'hôpital non tu as des
blagues
sa longueur partie aller chez leur
grand-mère mais il ramassait il ramasse
leur vent aussi si vous avez une
amène des fleurs vous avez un bâton dans
la main qu'est-ce que vous faites avec
votre bateau
avec un bouquet de fleurs et moi je vous
assure que les gardiens
ah oui oui toute façon moi je suis
vraiment une révolte hein
oui oui tout à fait pour l'instant ça ne
s'arrange pas toute façon quand je
l'avais dit je pense qu'on est sur une
année très compliquée et je ne vois pas
les choses vraiment s'améliorer en tout
cas on parle beaucoup de l'inflation
mais moi l'inflation pour moi elle va
continuer on va pas ça va pas ça va pas
s'arrêter tout ça non moi je sens pas du
tout et je pense qu'on va remonter la
pente sur le 2025 2026 mais pas avant